okay Dr.  Emily Food Cider, der
Nevada genau die CNEA-Designs falsch diagnostiziert, und
David Scott Alfred, ich weiß, Carly
Organisation würde Peter Florrick den
Pokemon-Rat geben, der Lucario für
Dunford Angelina ist, der
hier am frühen Krieg in der Nähe seines Gesundheitsereignisses sehr ähnlich ist.
Ich habe mein Alamou Cooper-
Haus und  AB Karpin duster duster
das ist die Erfindung des Sprichworts
Shah Pahlavi Ich bin Gluten Fenton und
Lucario Desaster Pokemon wie mit
- Ich bin Mafia hier
Machida Miss Lynch Griffin Hör Boosha
Boosha Fisch Megan
hol uns
ab heute Abend hierher und frag  alle -
Pokemon das hier bei ich plus du
musst fertig werden Pop ist Nordkorea Tochter
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott Taser sagt das ich
sage vermisse den alten Kapitän
niemand kann mich aufhalten private Münder [ __ ]
wir feiern eine Party, aber wir wollen  ein buch
von versucht den angriff anzugreifen eine art
besserer von wir müssen da drüben auftauchen
sie wachsen auf dem baum ein taschenball ein
weiterer pokerboy und hier der
letzte superball und jetzt 3  0
du wirst schlachten - sieh dir eine effektive
Show an
Es
kommt, es kommt aus der Kamera,
komm schon, es ist ein Feuer,
wir werden es fangen, oh ja, groß, gib mir was,
fang, oh nein, ein anderes Pokémon, das es
aufhält
das tödliche
es schläft
wir brechen aus oh nein es bewegt sich es
bewegt
ich glaube ich habe meinen Charakter verloren ich kann es nicht mehr halten
ich kann nicht ich kann nicht
Kerl, gehören sie noch dazu, um
zu reden, gehören, oh mein Gott
, um einen Moment zu finden, der Pokerbot ist hier,
jetzt ist das Richtige für mich, welche Gedanken sich
drehen
Es ist in Ordnung, ehrlich zu sein,
Lucario, viel Spaß mit
dir  Burned the Well Committee bringt es auf
Englisch, weil dies ein internationaler
Vlogging-Kanal ist, der jetzt den letzten Fangplatz macht.
Was Sie drin haben.
Wir haben es gelb zum Zoo. Danke, Mann
deine
Wutdecke durchschnittliches Element Fisch kedem macht deine
Mutter zweites Lucario jetzt, wo wir gefangen haben,
kannst du den Rucksack modellieren, jetzt kannst du
uns dein Zuhause zeigen, wenn du das gut willst
, ich habe sie alle, einige Kinder sind
zu Hause, Kinder, einige Kinder waschen es  Ein
Rechteck aus jetzt auf diesen Telefonen aus,
gerade wenn Sie sogar verdammte
Sandfallen in Konasana hochfliegen oder Allah nicht glauben